so much to celebrate right now number
one Youngblood in Canada right yeah and
back on tour you've got like legions of
fans waiting for you all across North
America it must feel like a great time
to be fire sauce right now it's in time
to be in five sauce I'd say yes
fantastic I think you know it's just a
icing on the cake it's just going number
one them spent a lot of time working on
this record so we're really proud that
it's being reciprocated over here in
Canada yeah did you guys celebrate in
any particular way when you took the
number one spot over the carters
honestly we were on a plane and that
plane was delayed for like six hours or
something so everyone was really bummed
out and then the pilot comes on the
thing we've already been sitting on the
tarmac for like two hours or something
and the pilot comes on that
whatever-you-call-it in to come hey
what's up we're gonna be on the ground
for another like three hours and then we
got told by manager like just after and
then like we get up with such hearing
and we're really stoked and everyone's
like why you guys so excited and then we
get off the plane and head McDonald's so
overall it was fantastic
ya know that sounds like I wish I wish I
could have been there with you guys that
was good right yeah I mean there's this
perception I think about about celebrity
isn't about you know rock-and-roll bands
like you guys that it's kind of like a
party every day that everything is a
celebration all the time and that's like
the perfect story to kind of just say
well you know sometimes you get stuck in
a plane and it doesn't turn out the way
it is but you know it's it's been a good
time right still yeah it's definitely
it's not as glamorous as everyone thinks
but I know I think for us particularly
we're definitely why definitely lucky
that you know web four best friends in a
be honest then and that sounds simple
ain't but like like we actually get to
like enjoy each other's company all of
the time and and you know we make the
best of every moment and you know it's
refreshing to to to have these like
incredible things happen to us again and
to be able to experience them as adults
and as men yeah well I mean you guys
have been at this for quite a while you
were like 16
when you know you guys first broke big
so you know looking back would you have
done anything differently would you give
your younger selves any advice
I don't know I don't think you're doing
any differently I think that's where we
are or we out today I mean that what we
always say actually so express the only
thing I do is probably uh
I don't know I told myself to get some
better clothes or yeah when I get some
new pants or something I don't know well
you caught up to yourself like yeah you
got it now yeah I don't think no I think
it's why we yeah exactly it's why we are
worried about today I think you know
going through those things and you gotta
make mistakes to to grow and yeah so I
wouldn't really change anything
maybe not release a few of the b-sides
are released but uh you know puffs from
that no not at all
its Fame kind of everything you expected
it to be for back in the day I mean it's
it's very different with us I Hank
because you know we'll still you know
the biggest band that nobody's ever
heard of you know what I mean like like
we have we have our core fans that come
and see us at like these shows and we
play these like massive shows to these
like you know incredible fans but also
like we're not like we're not famous huh
[Laughter]
we're not like typically famous you know
what I mean so I think it's still
something that that for us is you know
we're still normal people but I mean
that's an interesting take to have on
the whole thing you know the people that
come out to see you are they're in love
with you and they'll go to bat for you
and they'll defend you and they'll
they'll talk about you and sing your
praises all the time but do you want
that level of Fame where you know like
that jay-z level of Fame where everybody
in the world knows who you are
knows your face wants to know everything
about you I think you know that kind of
Fame either comes to you when you do
something great or when you do something
absolutely terrible so hopefully we're
always striving to to achieve greatness
and I think that's something that we've
done with this latest album that we're
confident that we've done and achieve so
yeah we're really proud is there any
significance to the title Youngblood
I think Youngblood as the title the
album is the way we're living in a time
where we felt and the powerfulness of
the album to us and also the title track
is Youngblood it's our favorite song as
a ban on the album and when we got that
song we knew we had something special
now album was you know completed so I
think yeah I mean personally there is
and as a band there isn't for that song
kind of like leading the charge I would
say yeah and all those reasons yeah um
you know watching you guys from I guess
kind like the beginning of your career
the thought dawned on me that a lot of
young artists are expected to put out
albums like year after year after year
after year like always new product all
the time and you guys decided to take a
bit of a hiatus was that more like you
needed mental clarity the you need break
from each other and also did you get any
pushback from anyone with that decision
it it was you know it was something that
was necessary for us I think that we had
to do that in order to make more music
you know because we were you know we
just we did so much in the the years
that we were touring and making music
and I think that you know we we made all
of the right decisions but I think that
you know we needed to take we needed to
take a second and and kind of reevaluate
what our goals were from this band and I
think you know we we really had to
picture the long-term vision for this
band which is being a band that's gonna
stay together for a really long time and
you know when we when we originally
decided that we would like hey we're
gonna take our time on creating the new
era for 5 seconds of summer I mean
obviously everyone was like are you sure
you want to do that like why don't you
just make an album into another three
weeks and put it out you know but but if
for us was you know we just had to do it
and and it's why we're gonna be able to
to stick around for longer than I think
anyone wants it wasn't sometimes not
necessarily like a choice by the end of
it like you have to have the right songs
and we knew had to come back with
like like fully game changing in layout
different unique and I think we did that
and it doesn't happen in you know three
weeks or whatever one frame you get I
think it shows a lot of confidence in
each other and then you know in your
band in your product that you could take
that time away to reassess and
reevaluate when you guys were doing that
what kind of conclusions did you come to
about who 5 seconds of summer is how you
want to continue on and how you're going
to get that longevity that you guys
talking about yeah think it was the
first time that we've really tapped into
the individual artists within 5 seconds
of summer because these guys are you
know they contain so much creative
energy and they have so much potential
and ambition to you know achieve great
things for themselves within this band
and that's something you know the
accident realize anytime it's just for
the cameras I think that's something
that we realized and and you know a lot
about this album that we made was was
self realization and was awareness to
where this band wanted to end up and
where it wanted to be at this point in
time so I think it's an everyday process
like it's a noise a reoccurring thing
and it's constant thing that we're
always thinking about and that's why I
love being in this band is because we're
always pushing the boundaries in that
you know we're never content with what
we have when you guys did take that
break did you take a break from
everything I mean the fans want to be
connected to you all the time so I think
it's kind of interesting the idea that
you know you're not putting out product
but they must have been still clamoring
for more and more and more and for you
guys to be there kind of to reassure
them was that something that you thought
was very very important I mean honestly
we kind of ghosted them we hosted them
for about a year you know and we were
still I mean we were still kind of I
mean we toured at the end of 2017 but
but that was a full year break for us so
I mean really we just kind of immerse
ourselves into creating an album and and
you know that was because we knew that
that was what was gonna matter and
the bigger picture of things rather than
than us just being like hey we're still
making an album like 12 months later
yeah you know well talking about heading
back on the road you know you guys are
doing your North American tour it's all
coming up now how do you guys prepare
for a big trip like that
no mentally I think you get better at
Tori and physically I suppose as you get
older I don't know we kind of what do
you do you do yoga kind of workout
getting shape a little bit
can't be too round on stage I suppose
gotta be in shape
gotta be able to sing the songs a lot of
vocal lessons yeah tonight we kind of
with this show in particular it's
definitely a step forward our live act
is the best I mean is we want to be the
best live act there is we are the best
life we are the best and we we're always
striving to be you know we're gonna
compete with other acts out there that
aren't exactly a bands you know like
bands like 2000 pilots and Penacook
disco and stuff he we got abstract to be
in that kind of league you know
if not further above sir I mean we're
always putting so much evidence when the
lighting shows incredible on this on
this tour I'd say the best we've ever
had
yeah you know yeah see I don't know many
I didn't really prepare that much I
think that that time making the album
was I mean what start ready to play
those songs on stage we played a few
like in Australia in Japan and the new
songs are going down great off
Youngblood yeah and people love them so
I mean that's been amazing what would
surprise your fans about touring life
that they don't know I think it's more
of a mental battle than people realize
okay it's it's a you know it's a it's a
big test for for our minds and that's
why we always have to you know keep them
in check
yeah do you know what city you're in
every time you go yes I do now yeah I do
now I'm pretty good I definitely did not
know used to know what city were in my
death well this time I didn't know where
I was for the first like four years
that sounds like yeah there you go
awesome thanks guys